i do want to clarify that the whole
point that i'm showing these weaknesses
in fractional reserve lending isn't to
argue that it necessarily has to go away
or that it is somehow unviable it's
clearly viable it's the system that most
market economies actually all that i
know of used today but the reason why
i'm doing is to show that it's not the
only type of system and that we really
should scrutinize any systems that we
have in place to realize that they
aren't
they aren't a law of physics that we
have to have fractional reserve lending
that in order to have this system
function there has to be kind of
engineering in place and there still are
some drawbacks the unstability in order
to combat that you need to have central
bank insurance and you also have to have
the central bank as a lender of last
resort of reserves the bad incentives
and these are well documented these
aren't just coming for me bad incentives
when you look at uh some
if you if you are looking to invest in
any other type of investment company
someone who's taking your money and
investing it on your behalf they would
typically be talking about how good they
are in investing money but most when you
look at commercial banks that's not what
they're talking about because they know
that that's not what consumers care
about because of the insurance there
they will talk about things like how
easy it is to access your money with
their atms and their online banking and
how low their fees are they won't even
bring up the idea that hey we're lending
your money and we're lending it in
really really responsible ways and it is
also well documented by having a
fractional reserve lending system it is
putting a significant amount of the
money creation system essentially the
checkable deposits it's putting it in
the hands of private banks as opposed to
the central banking authority now with
that out of the way
you're probably saying well are there
any other alternatives and i'm not
advocating one or the other but i'm just
showing you that this is not necessarily
the only way that we would have to set
up our banking system in fact the
original way is the alternative the
original way would be full reserve
banking
full
reserve
reserve banking and it is exactly what
it sounds like which is that a bank
would have to if someone puts reserves
or cash dollar or federal reserve notes
in their demand deposit account then the
bank would just have to keep it there so
if i have a bank right over here
if i have a bank
and if i were to put three dollars
three dollars three federal reserve
notes here
three federal reserve notes here and if
i were to say that this is in my i want
to have this on demand i want to be able
to go to the bank at any moment in time
and be able to take these things out
then the bank would have to keep all of
these reserves there and you might say
well well then how will lending happen
and all the rest in order for lending to
happen the bank would have to say hey
look you don't you're not going to need
to have all of this on demand why don't
you keep some fraction of this on demand
maybe it's this dollar bill right over
here
and the rest of these we the bank will
literally borrow that from you and this
this isn't an actual foreign concept
when you go buy a certificate of deposit
at a bank when you put your money in a
cd at a bank that's essentially what the
bank is doing they are borrowing that
money from you they're making it
explicit they're not saying that that
money will be on demand they're saying
this is a time deposit that this money
you are giving it to us now and then you
can get it back in six months or a year
or two years or whatever and usually the
longer the duration the longer you keep
your money you lock your money in with
them the higher the interest they would
pay so they'll say look this is on
demand
this is on demand that's in a demand
deposit and then this right over here
you will loan it to us this is a time
deposit
this is a time deposit and then the bank
could loan this money out it could loan
these reserves out but this this loan
process would not increase the money
supply so that money could be loaned out
maybe to someone else and maybe that
gets deposited another bank maybe in a
demand deposit
so it gets let's say it gets deposited
right over here in a demand deposit you
might say well isn't this just like
fractional reserve lending now you have
five dollars in a system the difference
is is that no one can now use this
perceived this perceived money right
over here as money you wouldn't be able
to write checks against this money right
over here you could write it against
this over here and that's okay you could
write a one dollar check and it's backed
by this one dollar of reserves so you're
not creating any new money the only the
only reserves here that are really can
either act as money or be used to back
checks are now the original three
dollars
the original
three dollars here and the value of this
type of a system and there are drawbacks
to it the main drawback is that the bank
is not going to be able to make any
money on its demand deposits and so it
will probably have to charge higher fees
to customers to keep their money they'll
say hey i'm safeguarding your money i'm
putting it in a vault for you i'm making
it accessible to you through checks
through atms so i'm going to charge you
more money for you to keep for me to
essentially safeguard your money right
now what banks are doing in fractional
reserves system is like hey we'll do all
of these services for you for a lot less
sometimes even free if you keep large
enough deposits with them we're going to
hold your money for you you're going to
keep it
accessible on atms we're going to give
you a bank atm card
and all of these things and the reason
why the bank is able to do that is
because they're essentially doing they
are lending out a significant fraction
of your money and getting interest on it
and that's how they're making money here
it just becomes much more explicit the
bank is saying look on this right over
here we are doing a service for you we
are holding your money we are keeping it
on demand from wherever you want to
access it and over here you're doing a
service for us you are lending us your
money and then we are going to lend it
out probably for higher interest and we
so that way we can make money off of it
and obviously if we were to convert to
some type of a system like this there
wouldn't just there wouldn't be as much
money being created or actually no money
would be created by this lending process
and so the central bank or whoever the
monetary authority is in the country
would have to essentially print more
money to have the money available to
essentially be the greece in the economy
and just to make it clear that this
isn't a fringe idea that this is
essentially what banking was until the
mid 14th century and it was the venetian
bankers who first brought up the idea of
fractional reserve lending and there
were some very mainstream banks that did
full reserve lending into the 1800s and
in the kind of as the great depression
got longer and longer in 1939 some very
serious economists proposed a a
reversion back to full reserve banking
and they even articulated exactly how it
would do and how and how it would not
introduce uh introduce too many too many
uh interruptions to the economy although
anything like this would be dangerous
because you are introducing a whole new
way of doing things and you don't know
exactly what the repercussions would be
on the economy if you want to read their
proposal it's actually quite fascinating
and just reading their proposal
you'll get more depth on how the
monetary system works it's written by
mainstream economist look up do a google
search for a program a program for
monetary reform
for
monetary
monetary reform and it was written in
1939 so you can also do google for that
and on wikipedia there's actually the
full text of a program for monetary
reform and when it was when it was
published it was supported actually by a
majority of mainstream economists to go
to a full reserve banking system